biden's going to
have a fairly conventional view of
america's
predominance in the world china's been
able to gain a lot of ground
internationally by playing off
the us against europe one of the most
important
differences between biden and trump is
biden does
believe in diplomacy china has shown
itself to be highly pragmatic
in terms of its foreign relations with
the us
[Music]
the u.s election was a month ago the
legal challenges are all over by the
tweeting
so a presidential transition is now
fully underway for president-elect biden
how he manages the relationship with
china is likely to shape his presidency
and a big part of how the world works ed
you've written a lot
about the impact the trump presidency
has had on the us's standing in the
world
and that his reframing of the west's
attitude towards
china is regarded in the us
as one of his biggest achievements so
what would you say are the key
topics that are going to define the u.s
china relationship in the next four
years
so the most surprising thing i think is
just the element of continuity here
as you say trump has kind of branded a
new bipartisan
attitude towards china which sees it not
as a potential partner
any longer but which season is a threat
a strategic
rival and that includes democrats um
there was uh in my view less uh
cytophobia in the presidential election
than you might have expected but it was
still quite a lot and it
pushed biden quite sharply to the right
in terms of where he used to be
as vice president a much more hawkish
voice
on china so i would expect the bible
administration
to pick up from trump in terms of
hawkishness on trade and on the deficit
and on intellectual property
i would expect there to be considerable
uh
attempt to shore up america's military
presence in the region um to continue
that
arms race if you like with china but
also
and here's the real departure from trump
to
to approach china with allies with
partners not through an america first
um prism but through multilateral means
one of the most important differences
between biden
and trump is biden does believe in
diplomacy he does believe in working
with allies he does believe in what i
call the constant gardening
of talking to people and working in
concert with them
and he believes in the multilateral
system and this means a couple of things
first
that he's going to try and work with
europe and with america's
allies and partners in the asia-pacific
region to
to develop a common approach to china on
a range of issues
um but he's also going to perhaps a bit
more controversially and
really in stark contrast to to trump and
even to obama
uh is to set up a conference of
democracies
in other words a kind of ideological um
sort of rivalry
to china's authoritarian model a a
conscious
sort of ideological opposition there
that has been lacking um
in u.s foreign policy at least since the
the iraq war um now this common approach
whether it's sort of a la carte
mini lateralism with allies who want to
join in or
more conventional multilateral
presumably
james is not something that xi jinping
and the
china leadership wants wants to see
it's really uh china's worst nightmare
um
for the last 40 years of china's phase
of reform and opening up to the outside
world
china's been able to gain a lot of
ground internationally by playing off
the us against europe and
and really winning some concessions
in the process if the vision of the
future
is the u.s and europe working together
to constrain china in some way
that really closes off a lot of doors
to the chinese leadership but i think
there is a valid question as to whether
or not
the the u.s and the eu can actually pull
this off
um there's an awful lot of coordination
that would be required to
actually achieve this type of
constraining attitude towards china
and i think if we look at the cards that
china has in its hand
you know you you quickly see how
difficult it could be
obviously the main one is commerce and
trade
china is the biggest trading country in
the world
has a huge surplus with the u.s has a
big surplus with the eu
there are all kinds of trade levers and
other commercial levers
that the chinese can pull to frustrate
and prevent
the us and the eu working together
against
china
biden will have the same sort of overall
view that the commercial relationship
with china is of transcending
importance uh that trump has but it will
be a
very different very different approach
to um
how he handles it uh trump saw it as
in very much 20th century terms as
where the bilateral um trade deficit was
distributed on
aluminium or steel or whatever it might
have been or soybeans
biden won't be obsessed with that his
team are looking more at the strategic
investment driven high-tech stuff
particularly in
ai and 5g
and the strategic advantages as well as
the commercial advantages
that that china is gaining on the united
states and i don't think they see the
trump administration as having really
addressed any of that
so they will share one thing which is
china is a grand commercial strategic
threat but
at that point tactically they they are
biden and trump are in different
universes from a chinese perspective
they look at the
trade war that trump launched in 2018
and i think they feel that it hasn't
gone that badly
for instance in the last few months the
chinese trade surplus with the us
has been rising very sharply indeed i
think a lot of observers
in this part of the world when they
think about the trade war
they think that china may have won
but the points that you mention you know
the sanctions
by the u.s government on key chinese
technologies
particularly in areas such as artificial
intelligence and 5g telecoms and
sanctions directed at particular chinese
companies such as huawei
i think in those areas china remains
very exposed
and those sanctions have been very
painful
for particular chinese companies so um
while the leadership in beijing would be
wanting those to be eased or lifted
i think they're realistic in in knowing
that progress on that front is pretty
unlikely
but beyond trade and and this type of
commercial relationship ed
let me ask you how do you see a
president biden dealing with the
geostrategic
rivalry that's come to characterize the
u.s china relationship
well the interesting thing james is that
you know biden's going to have a fairly
conventional view of
um america's predominance in the world
and the
the need to maintain its hegemony in the
asia pacific
so there'll still be patrols of u.s
naval
freedom of navigation patrols in the
south china sea there will still be a
strong
treaty alliance with japan there will
still be military exercises probably
more
emphasized with the quad of u.s japan
australia and india
it'll be referred to as indo-pacific so
that conventional role um you know the
that america has always had
in which um obama stepped up with a
pivot to asia
biden will pick up on update and
strengthen
uh there's there's not going to be any
radical departure there from
the standard american administration
very radical departure
though from trump because there will be
strong emphasis
on you know hong kong's freedoms or
diminishing freedoms
on the xinjiang situation uh they'll
probably meet the dalai lama at some
point
so that that's something that china will
not like and with which it will be very
familiar
on the other hand biden wants to work
with china um he wants to reach out
and and develop common positions on on
issues like climate change
without china very little can be
accomplished with china you can get
dramatic global progress and the
appointment of john kerry
you know as biden's climate envoy
is a signal that you know biden doesn't
just want rivalry with china
he also wants friendship you could call
it a sort of frenemy
a frenemy situation so my question to to
you james is
can china do this sort of walking and
chewing gum of being a rival and
and a cooperator at the same time would
it will that work
yes i think you know walking and chewing
gum for china
is situation normal in international
relations i mean
i think for probably a decade or more
before
the trump uh presidency began china
became
used to balancing rivalry on the one
hand and
cooperation with the u.s on the other
so i really don't think that this will
be a stretch of course
when the u.s criticizes china on human
rights that will annoy beijing
and there will be some kind of a
backlash
of course there'll be other irritations
many other irritations
in the relationship but but china has
shown itself to be highly pragmatic
in terms of its foreign uh relations
with the us
however this time around i think there
is one
area that is significantly different
from
pre the trump presidency and that is the
situation and the tensions around taiwan
taiwan is regarded by china as an
inalienable part of its territory
but more and more is showing
self-determination
under the encouragement of the us if
tensions over taiwan
start to really spiral then we are
genuinely
in new territory and very scary
territory i think for the whole region
and and and for the rest of the world